[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade was ich
hier mache und ich war mitten im wald in
waghäusel
und heute geht's um schneidebretter und
ich wollte einfach ein bisschen
lockerheit reinbringen und wir sehen die
hose der christbaum in die beste trage
und zwar ihr lacht jetzt vielleicht
darüber aber im wald eine weste tragen
ist immer wichtig weil es wurden schon
40 jogger von jägern geschossen weil sie
für ein
tier gehalten wurden ja natürlich sind
hier so muss gelöst wie ich bin könnte
es auch eine wildsau sein nein aber ich
bin es und zwar heute diesem video
geht's um holz und zwar um dieses holz
her um schneidebretter ich weiß dass ihr
alle darauf gewartet habt mich natürlich
meinen rückenbereich und zwar ein
schneidebrett aus holz ihr fragt schon
die ganze zeit danach will er schon seit
einem jahr in unseren videos seht wo wir
unsere schneidebretter herstellen lassen
weshalb und wie zeige ich euch jetzt in
diesem video nehmen euch mit auf eine
ganz ganz tolle reise wir gehen zuerst
nach düse düse ist in der
schwarzmeerregion die türkei da komm ich
her und da werden diese schneidebretter
hergestellt aber nicht nur dort sondern
auch in malsch und das wird jetzt eine
richtig tolle reise und zwar die reise
dieser schneidebretter wer ist
produziert wie wann weshalb warum keine
ahnung
ok ich freue mich drauf und kommt
einfach mit
[Musik]
ja wir sind hier in düster in der in der
provinz ist eine provinz hier in der
schwarzmeerregion da wo ich herkomme ja
und auf jeden fall ist es der region die
vom handwerk lebt weniger von der
dienstleistung ist wirklich handwerker
hier und hier auch in diesem restaurant
hat das alles schon alles gemacht die
ganzen tische und stühle das ganze
interieur design hat komplett der saal
ich gemacht und so sind übrigens auch
auf wien gekommen und wir gehen jetzt
einmal besuchen nachdem wir diesen
ausblick einfach genossen haben
[Musik]
nach den wäldern von duchess sind wir
jetzt hier in der holzbearbeitung hier
holte sich übrigens caesar der der
meister holte sich muster der holt hier
sein holz und so 7 kambala baumhaus also
die rinde ist relativ weich aber wenn
man die berühmte weg macht kommt man zu
dem steinharten holz hier ist auch ganz
wichtig ist eine riesengroße firma das
heißt alles was du hier siehst was was
ihr hier seht ist fsc zertifiziert das
ist ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtig dass es
nicht um seinen hinterhof laden ist
sondern mit einer riesen fabrik wurde
das zeitlich seine hölzer erholt
fsc-zertifiziert aus nachhaltigen
landwirtschaft und das ist das perfekte
holz für schneidebretter weil es
ziemlich hart ist
[Musik]
container für die pandemie hier hat man
immer sagte fink dem deutschen sammler
sagt ich kann also er sagt mir gerade
aufgrund der pandemie es merken wo man
in deutschland auch die haben wir kein
holz mehr in deutschland möglich waren
sie mehr als klopapier draufgegangen ist
natürlich nicht aber er sagt gerade dass
die das momentan weniger bäume gefällt
werden was ja auch nicht schlecht ist
aber ist noch weniger verarbeiten preise
haben sich verdoppelt und verdreifacht
auch die ganzen container preis sehr
teuer geworden und deswegen ist holz
momentan richtig jahres gut und die
haben momentan auch richtig
wirtschaftliche probleme weil das holz
hier immer teurer wird
aufgrund der pandemie konnten sie nicht
arbeiten
arbeitsplätze sollen abgebaut es ist
alles teuer geworden aufgrund der
pandemie schlägt sich auf den hohe
holzpreis definitiv nieder
ja es ist samstag und heute arbeitet
keiner und normalerweise werden jetzt
diese großen holzstämme genommen hier
drauf gemacht und dann hier zurecht
geschnitten in balken bretter und ein
drum und dran genau
[Musik]
so sehen die bretter aus und sie heute
stellen sie geschnitten sind aber nicht
jedes holz ist für schneider ist ganz
ganz wichtig aus vielen häusern auf
appelle wie zum beispiel werden möbel
gemacht gartenmöbel wälzt eine art
teakholz ist und walnuss damit macht man
halt mal nüsse oder halt möbel genau
möbel design objekt design für banken
oder für hotels und allem drum und dran
[Musik]
und nachdem ins holz angekommen ich aus
amerika aus aus den usa das eichenholz
nach dem holz aus zaire gekommen ist und
auch die eigenen eigene holzer hier die
aldi die heimischen hölzer wie eiche
wird hier alles getrocknet diesen
riesigen trocken höfen jetzt war ich mal
kurz auf und schauen ob es reicht jetzt
wird es laut
[Musik]
auf jeden hat das ein sektoren drin die
sensoren messen die luft luft
feuchtigkeit im holz
93 tagen ist es wirklich trocken und
fertig zur verarbeitung grüße gehen raus
in österreich kasse
treffen
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir hier in der
schreinerei und jetzt haben wir diese
die symbole diese aus dem eigentlich aus
dem holz werk kommt dies jetzt
getrocknet und jetzt wenn wir diese
waldkante rau weg machen damit wir diese
coolen steht zusammenkriegen das heißt
einmal einfach diese waldkante weg das
muss durch den maschinen durch schieben
kann der sergeant er macht das jetzt
sehr
genau jetzt schaut sie immer an
[Musik]
und dieses material hier wo gehobelt
wird da fallen späne heißt es ja und
dieses material wird als füllmaterial
für irgendwelche verpackungen benutzt
oder aus dem werden auch pellets gemacht
das heißt alles was das holz hergibt
wird wieder verwenden ist ganz ganz
wichtig
wir werden von grob immer feiner jetzt
sind da einfach diese bretter die wir
jetzt schon in der in der dicken hobel
hatten wie sie jetzt durch die breitband
maschine wahnsinn was begriffe geht ich
bin ich froh dass sie schnell erkennen
die ganzen maschinen und jetzt tun sie
das tun sie jetzt rein da kommen sie
noch fein raus haben
[Musik]
jetzt aber dieses brett von allen seiten
geschliffen und jetzt müssen wir aus
diesem brett das hier hin bekommen und
zwar dass alle vier seiten gleich lang
sind dafür war die frau bat kreissäge
und hier wird jetzt alles zusammen
geschnitten dass wir wirklich so ein
holz bekommen mit gleichlangen sein
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir die hälften geschnitten
haben sowieso würfel und lag zuletzt
hier rein und tuns verleimen das ist
eigentlich dass ganz normale verleiher
holz was ja eigentlich auch kennen und
hirsch ist wirklich ganz ganz wichtig
dass man einnimmt der lebensmittel echt
ist wir tun alle unsere punkten testen
lassen dass auch wenn ich ein
lebensmittel echter airline ist wie
gesagt alles zusammen ein dann haben wir
ganz normales bett um das brett haben
dann wird's komplett noch mal
geschnitten und damit wird die phase
nach oben genommen dass wir stirn holz
haben und dieser arbeitsschritt diese
diese mehrere arbeitsschritte machen so
ein brett richtig teuer aber die
qualität ist natürlich gigantisch
jetzt so zusammenbleibt hammer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
basta hier was sie hier sehen ist die
stirnseite vom holz die härteste stelle
von holz und die wollen wir nachher oben
haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so wird es ungefähr zehn stunden
getrocknet je nachdem wie es war - warum
es draußen ist mal sechs stunden auch
geht auch 100 bis zu vier stunden mehr
als 30 35 grad draußen ist dafür gibt es
auch maschinen muss man ganz ganz
ehrlich sagen wo das ding in ein paar
minuten pro clip nur das problem ist
gerade bei diesen schneidebrettern wenn
es zu schnell trocknet dann bekommst du
diese werbungen und es nicht cool
deswegen machen wir es auf diese art und
weise da müssen wir einfach das ist
komplett wirklich zu 100 % plan liegt so
ich mache das jetzt lieben fernsehen im
kochsendung ich habe da schon etwas
vorbereitet erzählt schon können jetzt
nicht warten deswegen hier haben wir so
verlangt es soll schon fertig nur dass
es jetzt freuen haben wir nämlich
kambala verleihen und dieses ein brett
nicht jetzt einfach ein ganz normales
verleiht das brett wir dass ein
schneidebrett erkennt aber wir möchten
ja daraus und stammholz machen deswegen
werden und dass jetzt einmal zusammen
segen und gehen in die nächsten schritte
long train noch mal einen drauf gemacht
und jetzt kommt es darauf an und zwar
jetzt nehmen wir diese dinge und drehen
sie um
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sieht das brett ungefähr nach 24
stunden aus nach 24 stunden das heißt
nach nach zwei mal zehn stunden
trockenzeit plus die ganzen
arbeitsschritt nach 24 stunden haben wir
so ein brett and green genau das was wir
haben möchten und hier muss man wirklich
saumässig vorsichtig arbeiten es geht
nicht schnell schnell weil hier muss
jede ist ganz ganz wichtig das was man
hier sieht das muss immer perfekt passen
wenn es nicht perfekt passt die ganze
linie wenn nicht durchgehen ist dann
können risse passieren da muss man
wirklich sagte arbeiten und mit aller
vorsicht behutsam arbeiten dass man
dieses ergebnis hinbekommt wir sind aber
noch lange nicht fertig das war jetzt
nur ein paar arbeitsschritte und jetzt
geht es zu den nächsten
so jetzt haben wir hier unser brett oder
ist noch nicht entlastet schneiden wir
hier komplett außen rum und machen wir
unser and mass bevor wir die sache rein
machen
[Musik]
so bei den schneidebretter haben wir
verschiedene versionen also nicht nur
beim holz also eiche und kabbala sondern
auch verschiedene größen dann haben wir
bretter mit griffin bretter mit ohne
griffen dann haben wir noch bretter mit
sattel und ohne sagte also alles
mögliche und hier zeigen wir euch mal
mit so einer cnc-maschine die sagt
riehle eingefräst wird eine ganz ganz
tolle geschichte wird nicht mehr per
hand gemacht sondern komplett mit der
maschine
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir es ja die sache
gemacht und jetzt möchten wir hier einen
perfekten radius haben wir sehr sehr
scharfkantig ich möchte mir perfekten
radios haben und dafür haben wir diese
tisch freese und maurus
kraß alte maschinen gibt ja also ich
kenne mit holz wirklich aus aber er ist
echt der wahnsinn was alles gibt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zwar habe hier ein exemplar
schleifer und die haben wir jetzt ein
bisschen grob geschnitten und das machen
jetzt alles per hand nichts passiert
druckluft ich brauche keinen motor und
mache ich jetzt
washington
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so jetzt habe ich es ja einmal
abgeschnitten jetzt gibt es noch eine
möglichkeit gibt zwei möglichkeiten ich
hole jetzt ein eimer mit wasser und tut
es brad rhein gucken wo es sofort wieder
raus oder ich nehme nasses tuch das geht
auch und tut es komplett nass machen das
ganze brett und das hat folgenden grund
meter brett hier komplett nass machen
dann dann stellen sich die härchen vom
holz die fasern nach oben und dann lass
es zwar zwei tage lang stehen und
natürlich nochmal abschleifen nachdem
ist normal abgeschnitten habe wo ist
noch mal wässern und dann stellen sich
die haare wieder auf natürlich wieder
abschleifen also ist ein prozedere der
ungefähr sechs tage insgesamt noch mal
dauert zwischen sechs und vier tagen
kommt darauf an und natürlich nochmal
abschneiden bis jetzt nass gemacht jetzt
merklich grad wie die ganzen fasern wenn
sie nach oben stellen noch mal
abschleifen und es dann allein schon
vier bis sechs tage wenig der wahnsinn
wie viel arbeit und viel zeit dahinter
steckt bis zum brett wirklich perfekt
ist
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir zum ölen von den
brettern es ist ganz ganz wichtig auch
später wenn ihr mal so ein brett benutzt
alle zwei drei vier monate her je
nachdem wie oft holzbrett benutzt mal
kurz abschleifen und nochmal nach oben
weil ihr müsst im holz immer eine
gewisse feuchtigkeit geben wenn es
holzbrett so trocken ist jetzt auch
risse dann müsst ihr aufpassen und dann
nehmen wir klug das kommt aus offenbach
aus deutschland hier steht auch
arbeitsplatten öl ganz ganz wichtig das
habe ich jetzt hier drauf im schwarm so
sieht es aus und das ist
lebensmittelecht ganz ganz wichtig nur
lebensmittel echterdingen benutzen beim
leine müssen wir nicht aufpassen ob es
auch wirklich in lebensmittelqualität
ist jetzt tue ich es gerade vom schwamm
und dann hier auf tragen
[Musik]
ja aus dem schönen duchess sind wir
jetzt im kraichgau gehen genauer
genommen in mal schmal ist ungefähr so
eine viertelstunde 20 meter von uns
entfernt und hier neben mir dieser junge
herr ist die neugier ist ein cooler
kumpel von mir hat schon einiges bei uns
im haus auch gemacht hat eine
schreinerei mit seinem vater zusammen
hat hier zwei auszubildende gleich
richtig 33 auszubildende
und macht hier einiges unter anderem
auch möbel und er ist eigentlich die
person die hinter diesen schneide bei
dann steckt weil er hat einfach die
kompetenz der über jahre hinweg und
jetzt werden noch weitere schritte mit
dem holz schneidebrett machen was machen
wir jetzt noch die veredelung was machen
ja die letzte veredelung wie du schon
sagst die sind ja indische schon alles
gehüllt worden und da wird ja auch der
trüben habe das ja alles kontrolliert
jetzt kommen sie nach deutschland
natürlich ist in deutschland einer
anderen luftfeuchtigkeit und so alles
das holz arbeitet und wir gehen jetzt
her und schleifen das nochmal drüber das
ist wirklich eine perfekte qualität
nochmals agiert und lassen das noch mal
mit ein genau was mir auto machen wir
machen noch unten machen wir noch füße
hin also nicht bei den länder verbände
brettern sondern gerade bei diesen
brettern mit diesem mit dem leder griff
dass die bretter nachher euch auf der
arbeitsplatte nicht rutschen dann auch
okay das war jetzt genau und rico kommt
auch mit das ist übrigens rico das ist
der vierte auszubildende dafür
auszuwählenden genau also kommt mit
[Musik]
schaffen wir jetzt was oder wollte ich
mir doch helfen ich bringe ihn gerade
paar grundstück in sachen bei
ja
ok
[Musik]
hier sind die verschiedenen bretter wir
haben ja über zwölf stimmen hier seht
ihr meine kleine auswahl also bei uns
ist es so in deutschland
günstiges holz wäre buche hochwertig
wäre hier ist immer noch hochwertig aber
weitaus günstiger als kambala als für
alle was dabei und der grund natürlich
war mir und ein detail produktion der
türkei gemacht haben ist so einenkel
grain brett wäre wirklich in deutschland
unbezahlbaren ist er wirklich für nur
für leute die wirklich sehr sehr viel
geld haben sondern brent preis 100 euro
hier in deutschland kaufen dann hast du
noch diese büffelleder griffe drin diese
messing schrauben als es wirklich ganz
ganz krass und ich hatte ja schon
anfangen im film schon erzählt ich komme
aus der schwarzmeerregion aus zehn
optisch ist noch ein bisschen weiter weg
aber es ist einfach eine infrastruktur
schwach region das heißt wenig
arbeitsplätze die leute leben wirklich
vom handwerk und das versprechen vom
vater der sieben gegeben habe dort
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen das war mir
ganz ganz wichtig deswegen dort zu
produzieren aber ich bin auch aus
waghäusel ich komme hier aus der region
auch hier arbeitsplätze zu schaffen neu
gemacht es richtig cool mit seiner
ganzen auszubildenden und seinen
mitarbeitern hier in malsch nicht weit
weg von uns deswegen diese kombination
passt dass man auch wirklich
schneidebretter sehr sehr hochwertig
anbieten kann aber doch noch zu einem
preis wo man sich leisten kann und man
könne nämlich entscheiden nämlich ein
kleineres brennt nämlich nämlich kambala
wir haben nachher die entscheidung
wichtig ist aber immer dass die qualität
stimmt und zwar bei allen brettern
vormonat hier haben wir jetzt einen
ständer baumaschinen was na ja doch
jetzt mit dem quatsch dies doch gar
nicht so laut ja wohl noch nie war sich
sicher ja was so hätte ich ja ja ja mit
modernsten oborne
aber nicht laut aber gut dass du dich um
die arbeitssicherheit der
arbeitssicherheit ist wichtig genau also
hier ständer baumaschine ich hab das
jetzt schon vorarbeit stellen und da tut
man jetzt die löcher bohren für die füße
und wenn man das gebaut haben das ist
nur die kiwis sich genau positiv ist
schlauer mensch weiß ganz genau worauf
bei der wii
[Musik]
aber passt es ja was
kann ich vorn
[Musik]
die nicht
genau aber jetzt sich schon aus wörtchen
jetzt
montags schleifspur was
ich schleife ist und zwar mit dem fest
ots 150 3 iq genau meine ist kurz und
zwar nämlich in 240er schleifpapier und
und mache alles weg
jetzt sind wir abgeschliffen und jetzt
thomas einen wir haben hier ein
spezialöl für
holzbretter zb wenn es daheim nicht habt
völlig genommen ihr könnt auch leinöl
nehmen ganz einfachen aber ganz wichtig
lebens gelegt und dann noch mal richtig
schön einmal genau machst du das ja
sonst
also ich ganz einfach ein baumwolltuch
tut es ins öl bisserl ein trunkenbold
einfach darüber reiben
da sieht man dann auch sofort dass das
holz angefeuert wird wir haben ja eine
schicht sozusagen abgeschliffen vom öl
und das holz weil nicht schützt und ich
bin ja mit dem er jetzt drüber gegangen
das holz wird sofort angefangen und
richter angeht ich mag ich mag das so es
ist all der holz geruch ist das richtige
holz geholt also
holz gebucht werden
wir haben hier zb so ein ganz ganz
cooles ich darf mich gar nicht sagen
desinfektionsmittel ist es eigentlich
nicht aber das tötet wirklich zu 99 9
prozent alle keime ab und hier ist kein
alkohol drin normales desinfektions
monaten sehr hohen alkoholanteil und das
trockenes holz ab und es ist wirklich so
einfach abspielt und dann das jetzt
rüber
und es war es komplett es ist voll
keimfrei gar keine probleme und immer
her wie casting ist das ist kein wasser
drin es ist wirklich
krass oder also irgendein als wohl spaß
da passiert nichts was wir jetzt auch
machen manche schneidebretter damit sie
nicht verrutschen haben wir extra noch
so füße dran
wir können jetzt noch rein drücken die
gehen nachher nicht raus so
so jetzt rutscht es auch nicht mehr im
märz zack und jetzt kommt noch die
ganzen leder kann die gibt es übrigens
mit oder ohne mit lehrer grip ist auch
cool zum servieren also die schneide
pressen so cool macht dass sie nachher
auch zum servieren nehmen kannst und
jetzt kommt noch die veredelung
[Musik]
und er bei der verpackung haben uns auch
richtig gedanken gemacht und zwar soll
das ja so eine richtig coole geschenke
boxen also das riechen box mit dem
magnet run gibt es mal ganz kurz
hier haben die ganze messe die wir haben
dann kommt das schneidebrett natürlich
hier rein
[Musik]
da kommt der stoff drüber damit die
packung nicht verhüllt und dann haben
wir hier noch ein zertifikat und was
auch cool ist das mindestziel
einschenken tun und diese person dass
sie versteht wie viel arbeit hinter so
etwas dahintersteckt nochmal schritt für
schritt erklärt wieso ein schneidebrett
gemacht wird
natürlich hier ein zertifikat und
bild von mir ich weiß dass hier kein
schwein aber ich wollte so machen wir
meine frau macht es auch immer rein und
ganz ehrlich dieses schneidebrett da
habe ich die meiste arbeit hinter gehabt
also wenn ihr dieses bild von mir habt
dann verschenkt an irgendjemand ja und
wenn man fragt wer das ist einfach
george clooney oder
genau so alles dabei
jetzt ist es wieder auch schon am ende
es hat mir richtig spaß gemacht und ja
unglaublich auch viel gelernt und
deswegen liebe ich ist ja was ich was
wir hier machen ich habe immer noch kein
schreien ja wenn kein schreiner aber bin
schon nah dran das heißt ich kann
mitreden und ihr wahrscheinlich jetzt
auch wenn es zum schneidebretter und
holzbretter geht indische haben sie
super arbeit geleistet muss ich ganz
ehrlich echt richtig top bin richtig
stolz drauf wir haben sehr hochwertiges
produkt produziert in allen formen in
allen größen
mit verschiedenen holzarten und jetzt
habt ihr auf jeden fall für die messer
richtige coole schneide unterlagen dann
gibt es nämlich auch das spray das könnt
ihr auch holen bringt euch auch weiter
ich bin einfach total platt jetzt auch
muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich sagen das war
jetzt ich verreise ja ja ich denke das
war wirklich nicht verreisen und als
nächstes machen mir messer haltern finde
ich auch eine coole geschichte haben
auch viele von euch angefragt daran
machen uns als nächstes habe ihr seht
ihr habt es nun ein bisschen video
angeschaut ist aber monate an
produktionszeit und an verarbeitung
normalerweise in die bretter viel
schneller raus kommen müssen hat es
leider so lange gedauert jetzt gibt es
die online und viel spaß ich bin richtig
glücklich nur dankeschön
macht's gut
[Musik]
okay das
matte und 123 und los
ich komme mir nicht hoch ich komme hier
nicht
hochklassig
ich komme
wie komme ich da hoch
schütte
herr spoerli bereichen hin die vereine
hier
ja stimmt ich hab es ja gar nicht
gearbeitet aber ich hab's ich habe
früher so hart gearbeitet dass ich seit
sechs jahren habe ich hier immer noch
raum hat keine ahnung das heißt ich habe
also ich habe irgendwie weg geht nicht
weg aber ja hat jemand verbrannt nein
das ist vom arbeitsunfall ich war schon
immer haben eingeklemmt ach du scheiße
ich aber das kann ich ja vorher nämlich
einer der wenigen schreiner der in dem
alter noch alle zehn finger hat sie
sofort sagen
33 wie außen müsse christi die jugend
aus dem sägewerk
genau wieso also 15 25 bier für die
männer aus dem sägewerk und
mein gott ich habe sie gefangen die
kinder nicht da ich hab die katzen
gefangenen kleinen babykatzen sind dann
hätte nummer 1 louis darauf was wir
verstehen nicht was sind das für terror
katzen ja wahnsinn oder matisse
[Musik]
das kleine kätzchen wo ich spaziere ich
hoffe dass jetzt auch ein buch gleichen
einfachheit steht für mit kätzchen am
fuß haste scheiße am fuß ich hätte auch
noch muss man ja ich komme sofort will
aber das spielt nicht hinaus
[Musik]